good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight if you're a normal
person it's a pretty weird experience
watching Joe Biden's presidency get
euthanized by his own party
on one hand there's an undeniable thrill
to it you have to admit that Biden is
the most destructive president in
American history more things have broken
under his watch than enter under any
other President Joe Biden deserves to be
driven from office and disgraced but for
this breaking Federal classification
rules some of the stupidest and most
dishonest laws Congress has ever passed
it's like a resting El Chapo for expired
plates it's missing the point
but it looks like that's what's going to
happen it seems like every day one of
Biden's lawyer shows up with more
sheaves of classified documents like a
dog who's found another dead chipmunk
under the house this Bunch was in his
office at Penn the one paid for by the
Communist Party of China these were
found next to his sad little midlife
crisis sports car in a garage in
Delaware and so on you keep waiting for
the White House physician to announce
another document Trove has been
discovered after a routine colonoscopy
it could happen because at this point
you know exactly where this story is
heading permanent Washington does not
want Joe Biden to run for president
again this is how they're sending that
message
even CNN has decided to become
interested in Joe Biden's misdeeds two
years into his presidency they're doing
segments on how classification laws
protect this country from its mortal
enemies like Russia
so you know for certain the order has
gone out Biden is done
what a missed opportunity this is if
you're looking for crimes that Joe Biden
has committed there is a very long list
our country is being invaded the world
is on the brink of nuclear war American
cities have become slums our economy is
in shambles even our airplanes no longer
take off on time it's a disaster and Joe
Biden and his staff have a hand in all
of it
in a country with a functioning
government Joe Biden would have been
impeached before the first million
illegal aliens crossed over our Southern
border but no one did anything to stop
it so now they're arriving at the rate
of a quarter million a month watch
Customs and Border Protection sources
exclusively tell Fox News more than 250
000 migrants were encountered at the
Border in the month of December about as
many people living in Scottsdale Arizona
making it the highest month ever on
record in Eagle Pass Texas the migrant
surge continues local Kinney County
Rancher Pam shot had a harrowing
experience with migrants on her property
and I looked out the back and I could
see he sent three illegals walking up to
the house I had gotten a gun which is a
AR-15 I asked him I said please you know
stop go away and had the gun in my hands
and they you know just kind of looked at
me and kind of smiled and I was like
Otto and just go away and they refused
to do so they're on the other side of
the glass
trying trying to get in and not backing
down not backing down even though I have
a high powerful rifle in my arms they
are not backing down that was scary
rifle Joe Biden would like to take away
from her
so that writ large is the biggest story
of our lifetimes it is the one thing Joe
Biden has done that cannot be undone our
great-grandchildren are going to live
with the consequences of this but you
never know it from watching most of the
news there's an effective media blackout
on Joe Biden's immigration policies and
other Downstream effects on America
there are too many strangers pouring in
at once and as a result the country is
becoming chaotic here's a rare
television news piece and what happened
when officials in New York decided to
house some of Joe Biden's illegal aliens
in a local hotel
an employee there says that migrants
have made an absolute mess of the place
you're standing in front of it is that
true
yeah well what we're hearing from that
employee is that the hotel is completely
overrun he says you know of course some
people just looking for that better life
but as a result the hotel is a mess and
he fears for his safety
we don't have any guests anymore
they
they sold the entire hotel from the
fourth floor to the 28th floor we saw
migrants so we got people who are
getting drunk using marijuana uh they
are punching and beating their wives or
their girlfriends we have teenagers
running around wild around the hotel uh
opening the fire exit doors and
doing what teenagers do in in the
stairways and it's a mess
it's a mess he said of course it is the
whole country is a mess because Joe
Biden has ignored immigration laws
passed by the Congress that is a crime
and it has killed huge numbers of
Americans hundreds of thousands dead
from narcotics
techno has changed the entire game here
in San Francisco you can't buy heroin
out here anymore nobody sells heroin and
nobody uses heroin everybody has
transitioned over to fentanyl the
fentanyl is The Most Dangerous Drug to
ever hit the streets of the United
States in history fentanyl has killed
more than 70 000 Americans in 12 months
here in San Francisco it's the dominant
drug it's responsible for three quarters
of drug overdoses raising drug dealing
and rampant drug use in the shadow of
City Hall the same city hall residents
say actively enable the fentanyl crisis
all of it every gram came over an open
border
so what's notable as a political matter
is that every one of these disasters the
fentanyl epidemic the chaos and crime in
our cities The Invasion underway through
Texas Arizona and California all of
those deeply concern Americans we're not
guessing at that polls show it very
clearly by contrast how many voters do
you think are lying awake right now
worrying that public officials might
violate some obscure Federal
classification law none not a single
person no one outside Washington cares
or even understands the issue
and yet it is classified documents not
our open borders that the justice
department is punishing Joe Biden for
why is that what's going on here well
it's simple Washington is protecting
itself
Joe Biden alone is responsible for this
crime he alone took home classified
documents he didn't have help in doing
that
but allowing the country to be invaded
that's not something you can do by
yourself
so if Biden were to be taken down for
opening the southern border a lot of
other people would go with them he had a
lot of accomplices
permanent Washington doesn't want that
and ultimately and here's the point
permanent Washington is in charge it's
not the Democracy you imagine we're
seeing that now
so if you want to understand if you
really want to understand how the
American government actually works at
the highest levels and if you want to
know why they don't teach history
anymore one thing you should know is
that the most popular president in
American history was Richard Nixon
Richard Nixon
yet somehow without a single vote being
cast by a single American voter Richard
Nixon was kicked out of office and
replaced by the only unelected president
in American history so we went for the
most popular president to a president
nobody voted for
wait a minute you may ask why didn't I
know that wasn't Richard Nixon a
criminal wasn't he despised by all
decent people no he wasn't
in fact if any president could claim to
be the People's Choice it was Richard
Nixon Richard Dixon was re-elected in
1972 by the largest margin of the
popular vote ever recorded before or
since Nixon got 17 million more votes
than his opponent less than two years
later he was gone he was forced to
resign and in his place an obedient
servant of the federal agencies called
Gerald Ford took over the White House
how did that happen
what's a long story but here are the
highlights and they tell you a lot
Richard Nixon believed that elements in
the federal bureaucracy were working to
undermine the American system of
government and had been doing that for a
long time he often said that he was
absolutely right
on June 23 1972 Nixon met with the then
CI director Richard Helms at the White
House
during the conversation which thankfully
was tape recorded Nixon suggested he
knew quote who shot John meaning
President John F Kennedy Nixon further
implied that the CIA was directly
involved in Kennedy's assassination
which we now know it was
helms's telling response
total silence
but for Nixon it didn't matter because
it was already over
four days before on June 19th The
Washington Post had published the first
of many stories about a break-in at the
Watergate office building
unbeknownst to Nixon and unreported by
the Washington Post four of the five
burglars worked for the CIA
the first of many dishonest Watergate
stories was written by a 29 year old
Metro reporter called Bob Woodward
who exactly was Bob Woodward
well he wasn't a journalist Bob Woodward
had no background whatsoever in the news
business instead Bob Woodward came
directly from the classified areas of
the federal government
shortly before Watergate Woodward was a
naval officer at the Pentagon he had a
top secret clearance he worked regularly
with the Intel agencies
at times Woodward was even detailed to
the Nixon White House where he
interacted with Richard Nixon's top
aides soon after leaving the Navy for
reasons that have never been clear
Woodward was hired by the most powerful
news Outlet in Washington and assigned
the biggest story in the country
and just to make it Crystal Clear what
was actually happening Woodward's main
source for his Watergate series was the
deputy director of the FBI Mark felt and
Mark felt ran and we're not making this
up the FBI's cointelpro program which
was designed to secretly discredit
political actors the federal agencies
wanted to destroy people like Richard
Nixon
and at the same time those same agencies
were also working to take down Nixon's
elected vice president Spiro Agnew in
the fall of 1973 Agnew was indicted for
tax evasion and forced to resign his
replacement was a colorless congressman
from Grand Rapids called Gerald Ford
what was Ford's qualification for the
job
well he had served on the Warren
Commission which absolved the CIA of
responsibility for President Kennedy's
murder
Nixon was strong-armed into accepting
Gerald Ford by democrats in Congress
quote we gave Nixon no choice but Ford
Speaker of the House Carl Albert later
boasted eight months later Gerald Ford
of the Warren Commission was the
president of the United States
see how that works
so those are the facts not speculation
all of that actually happened none of
it's secret most of it actually is on
Wikipedia but no mainstream news
organization has ever told that story
it's so obvious yet it's intentionally
ignored and as a result permanent
Washington remains in charge of our
political system
unelected lifers in the federal agencies
make the biggest decisions in American
government and Crush anyone who tries to
rein them in and in the process our
democracy becomes a joke
now you may have noticed that the very
first person in the Trump Administration
the agencies went after was General
Michael Flynn
why Flynn
because Mike Flynn was a career Army
Intel officer who ran the defense
intelligence agency in other words Mike
Flynn knew exactly how the system worked
and as a result he was capable of
fighting back
four days after Donald Trump's
inauguration the FBI lured Mike Flynn
into a meeting without his lawyer
concocted a series of fake crimes and
forced him to resign
so that's how things actually work in
Washington let's stop lying about it Joe
Biden meanwhile whooped like a hyena
when the justice department destroyed
Mike Flynn so there is we have to say a
certain perverse Justice in watching
something very similar happened to Joe
Biden himself six years later Joe Biden
does not deserve our sympathy
he's being shafted but don't weep for
him and yet the rest of us do deserve a
better system an actual democracy when
people nobody voted for run everything
you are not living in a free country
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight